good afternoon everyone
marta and i are heartened to see you on
our screens and we're joined today by
secretary and vice president for
university life kimberly
cruz
julia zukovitz a junior in franklin
college and university chaplain sharon
coogler
to everyone online thank you for taking
the time to participate in this vigil
for peace
all of us recognize
that the world is in a somber perilous
place
and over the past few days i've watched
with horror as i know you have
vladimir putin's invasion of ukraine
putin's aggression against a sovereign
independent nation
raises the specter of prolonged conflict
throughout europe
this is the largest ground attack in
europe since world war ii
we know from history that the risks of
miscalculation are dangerously high
and at yale we are compelled by our
common sense of humanity to reject this
violence in the strongest terms
we stand for peace
we grieve for the lives lost
we also support the students and
scholars of the yale ukrainian community
and those yale students and scholars
from elsewhere in the region
including russia who i am confident do
not support this invasion
i know many of our students and
colleagues are shocked and distressed
they fear for the future and for the
safety of loved ones and friends
over the past week yale staff and
faculty have been reaching out to them
to offer support
for example the office of international
students and scholars is working with
each affected student
or helping them with post graduation
plans employment authorizations and
travel needs
we're monitoring developments regarding
immigration options and sharing with
students and scholars relevant updates
for undergraduates from ukraine on
financial aid we will reevaluate the
financial aid awards they receive if
if there are changes
in in your economic
situation
we're advocating for policies that
protect the legal status of ukrainian
students and scholars in the us during
and beyond their studies here
we're supporting consultations with
immigration attorneys for ukrainian
students and scholars who need
assistance in navigating their future
status in the united states
in the days ahead
we will continue to work with individual
students in any way we can
in addition
faculty members on our campus are
helping policymakers think through how
to respond
the coming week the jackson institute
will be hosting an expert panel
discussion
we'll hear from faculty members who have
long studied the history of the region
and can share insights into the current
conflict and anticipate
what may come next
and how we can respond
i very much hope the scholars and
creative thinkers of our community can
help the world chart a path toward peace
right now
the spirit of division around the globe
seems stronger than ever
we must respond by embracing the ways we
are connected
not all of us work or study in fields
that can contribute solutions directly
to global global conflicts of this kind
but all of us play vital roles in
creating an environment of peace
and belonging at yale
and within all communities of which we
are apart
so let us treat one another and
ourselves with kindness and
understanding
let us approach our lives with gratitude
and with mindfulness
during this time of crisis
it gives me hope when i see our
community's commitment to one another
and to peace
please keep in mind
in your minds
the families
and friends who are in the ukraine right
now
with standing
and surviving
and combating
this unjustified barrage
thank you for joining us i'll now tune
turn things over to secretary and vice
president for university life
kimberly goff cruz
you president salovey
i joined the president in welcoming
everyone to this vigil for peace
we are here to support our ukrainian
faculty students staff and alumni as
well as those with ties to ukraine and
to find strength in one another
some of you may have been at the rally
on campus today and i know that there
are other events going on
this week including one today with the
symphony
tonight we create a virtual space to
join people around the world and praying
for an end to war in ukraine and for
peace
we know that events that seem rather
distant
have global effects they can touch
people around us and the people who are
important to them
of course we do not need to have
personal ties to ukraine to feel shock
fear and anger and to wish for peace
some of you here this evening may have
experienced violence or war yourself
we are grateful for your presence and
solidarity
we are profoundly affected by this
week's events because we care for
humanity in ukraine
in the world and at yale
so i encourage all of us to look out for
one another
especially people in your social
communities classes and work settings as
we process what is happening
if you need it
i encourage you to seek support whether
from your school or residential college
mental health and counseling the
chaplain's office our employee
assistance programs or of course from
friends and family
as these events unfold we will support
members of our community from ukraine
russia and the region in the ways that
president salovey described
we've got you we really got you
and we will continue yale's important
work to serve humanity and to make for a
safer healthier more equitable world
before i turn to our next speaker i
would like to share some of martin
luther king jr's remarks when he
received the nobel prize in
1964. he was speaking about the nuclear
arms race
but his words have resonance tonight
he said
so we must fix our vision not merely on
the negative expulsion of war
but upon the positive affirmation of
peace
we must see that peace represents a
sweeter music
a cosmic melody that is far superior to
the discords of war
somehow we must transform the dynamics
of the world's power struggle from the
negative
to a positive contest to harness man's
creative genius for the purpose of
making peace and prosperity a reality
for all of the nations of the world
if we have the will and determination to
mount such peace to such a peace
offensive he said
we will unlock
tightly sealed doors of hope
and transform our imminent cosmic elegy
into a psalm of creative fulfillment
again thank you for joining us
i will now turn to yulia zolkovitz a
junior in yale college and a citizen of
ukraine
hi everyone um thank you bitter
and thank you kimberly for everything
you said um my name is yulia and i'm a
junior in franklin and um i was born and
raised in ukraine um
as president salve and kimberly have
already mentioned
an unthinkable
is happening right now in my home
country in ukraine
on the 24th of february at 5 00 am
putin invaded ukraine invaded my home
country and forever changed my life and
lives of millions of other ukrainians
um i was lucky enough to
not be there when everything started and
not to be there right now and understand
and acknowledge how lucky i am but
millions of people who are still in
ukraine are not that lucky
everyone who is still in the major
cities and in the areas of active
military actions have to spend days and
nights hiding in the bombshell shelters
trying to protect themselves against the
russian missile attacks
however the ukrainian army has been
extremely successful with fighting the
russian forces
we won most of the crown battles and we
continue to stop the russian invasion
and continue to stop them against
progressing further into the country
it is really tough being away from home
and not being able to be there for my
family
but um
i hope as most of you um know there was
a 2pm rally for ukraine on cross campus
and um
by this i'm trying to support my country
support my family and do everything i
can being thousands of miles away i have
received incredible support from the
administration from my fellow students
from um other ukrainians at yale in
yale mad school and yale divinity school
from yale new haven hospital the support
that eel has given me has been
incredible and i cannot imagine a better
place to be right now
i urge all of you to
take a minute today to see to think how
lucky and privileged you are to be away
from the war right now
and how lucky you are to be in the us
um
or wherever you are right now where
you're tuning in um
not to be in the active military zone
where
the war against humanity the war against
one of the oldest nations in europe the
genocide of ukrainian people is
happening right now
thank you all for coming here this means
a lot to me this means a lot to my
family um thank you for tuning in and
i'm gonna
pass it to um sharon cugler the
university chaplain thank you
thank you so much julia you've shown
such grace and strength this last week
and our prayers are with you
my beloved yale family
this is a vigil calling for peace
and my words are intended to both
amplify that call
and turn it into action
our world this beautiful yet imperfect
world that we all share
breaks a little bit more every day we
have been living with a deep burden of
global unrest uncertainty
grief
and fear that is starting to feel
brutally defiant in its staying power
our spirits are suffering under the
stress of it all
and now here we are
gathered in this imperfect way across
these many screens
longing for connection
for reasons to hope
longing for multiple kinds of peace
what can we do thousands of miles away
from a new war
a new invasion to bring peace
this is a vigil
calling for peace
peace in ukraine where people are
fleeing
hiding or preparing to lose their very
lives in defense of their home their way
of life
this is a vigil calling for peace
peace in all places where aggression
poverty
ignorance
and violence oppresses and destroys
our human family
this is a vigil calling for peace
peace in our aching hearts
so that we can find the strength to keep
going and to be part of a kind of
healing that is restorative
this is a vigil calling for peace
peace in our minds
so that we can use them to create a more
just world
where power of means or might is used to
elevate the human condition
and to cherish our planet
this is a vigil calling for peace
peace in our relationships with others
where we can see and be seen
for the uniquely beautiful mysteries
contained
in each of us
this is a vigil calling for peace
peace in the light
peace in the dark peace in the big
peace in the small
peace in the weak
peace in the strong
this is a vigil calling for peace
one of my favorite prayers is also a
hymn
it's the prayer of saint francis
in its entirety it's a distinctly
christian prayer
however the first part feels accessible
to all people and it is in this moment
a much needed bomb for the soul
the prayer asks for us to be instruments
of god's peace
the prayer reveals that making peace
is in our hands
lord make me an instrument of your peace
where there is hatred let me sow love
where there is injury pardon
where there is doubt
faith
where there is despair
hope
where there is darkness
light
where there is sadness
joy
this is a vigil calling for peace
may you be shalom
may you be salam
may you be shanti
may you bring peace
i now invite you to join me in observing
a moment of silence honoring those
across the world particularly in ukraine
who have been lost
those who are grieving and those living
in fear for what might be coming next
focus simply on being still
let your mind turn to what it might mean
to be an instrument
of peace
thank you
this concludes the formal part of this
vigil
i invite you to linger a bit in this
zoom space we have arranged for a couple
of pieces of music to be played to
soothe your soul
let the music bless you
and then please feel free to leave when
you are ready and perhaps seek out a
friend to connect with over dinner this
evening
call a family member just to check in
or introduce yourself to someone new
and be an instrument of peace
thank you so much for joining us today
peace be with you
and god bless the people of ukraine
you